you not only look at the technology that
you're working on you're also looking at
what is coming
you know ahead of the time uh so what
are you trying to do
uh in in the future right because you
have the whole
engineering mindset you know with all
the technology at hand
as well as the problem at hand but at
the same time you're looking you're
interacting with your customers and
trying to understand their pain points
right
then you can easily relate oh okay if i
apply this technology to this problem
i should be able to solve this uh issue
for the customer so this is how the
uh you know engineering mind thinks
always trying to solve the problems
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel stanford leap and
birthright excel
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i'm honored to be joined by sriram
ravinu tala director of r d vmware
tsurami is director of rnd vmware a
cloud computing and virtualization
company
he runs an r d team across geos that
provide connectivity and services for
workloads
that run on multi-clouds using nsx
orchestrator
or that work based on k8's orchestration
sweram has delivered products that help
customers focus on the workloads or apps
rather than on the underlying
infrastructure
serums focus has now been to look at sas
based infrastructure services in a
multi-cloud scenario
sriram ravi nutella welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you today
good thank you michael thanks for this
opportunity i'm doing really great you
know
monday morning typically people get
blues but today i'm so excited you know
to be on your show and you know to talk
to you
thank you very very much i really
appreciate it and i'm excited in these
next 20 minutes to
dig deeper into your own journey you're
currently a director within the r d
department of vmware you're looking at
at cloud computing and multi-cloud
computing i'm excited to know
what what the multi stands for and how
that works in today's the
you know today's society but i'm also
curious to pick your brain
in in you know the aspect of leadership
and technology
and and you know being within these
great organizations and what you've
learned in terms of managing r d
departments and what are some things
that i can
you know think through and and perhaps
avoid or
or take into take into consideration so
let's start off with
a little bit about your own journey and
how how you end up
director within vmware absolutely
michael and i'm very happy to share that
uh journey with you it's it it's an
exciting journey to you know to be frank
uh i joined about nine years back with
vmware you know when it was young
and i was so excited to be part of the
uh
uh the cloud journey right from the
beginning because you know i came from a
systems background and now i jumped into
a software
only company i joined as a individual
contributor
and i i was fascinated by how
things move and how things actually are
done from the
management perspective rather than being
you know
doing a certain aspect of uh the product
so
that was what actually drove me to
become a manager
right and i was able to prove myself and
and moved laterally into management line
that's when i realized i did a big
mistake seriously at the time
it's not as if you know you you know the
managers that
i used to think was you know they sit
and do orders kind of a thing but
actually it's it's it's more than that
it's very tough you're dealing with
people you're dealing with emotions of
the people
right and you have to be really
confident enough to
uh do your job the right way so uh
i actually uh was you know then i got
motivated
of course you know uh i got you know
trainings all that stuff
then i moved into uh a role in within
the uh
organization as a manager um actually
managing a people of uh
12 a team a team of 12 people and uh
today you know i i actually grew
organically from then onwards and i grew
my team also you know i hired a big team
over here as well as in
in bangalore uh and uh today i'm i'm the
director
of one of the teams in vmware and i'm
very happy that you know i'm working for
vmware i'm doing the right things
and vmware is doing the right things and
i hope you know my journey will still
continue with vmware
uh you know to the next level and beyond
and so when you're looking at yourself
as an engineer
and and the leader in the technology
sphere what what comes to mind so what
are some
things that you know are immediately
apparently when you think of leadership
and engineering
sure absolutely so uh one of the uh
greatest things about being a leader in
the engineering role is
you not only look at the technology that
you're working on you're also looking at
what is coming you know ahead of the
time
so what are you trying to do uh in in
the future
right because you have the whole
engineering mindset you know with all
the
technology at hand as well as the
problem at hand
but at the same time you're looking
you're interacting with your customers
and trying to understand their pain
points right
then you can easily relate oh okay if i
apply this technology
to this problem i should be able to
solve this uh
issue for the customer so this is how
the uh you know engineering mind things
always trying to solve the problems
right so uh with that mind you
as a leader will make decisions you know
you'll make all strategic decisions to
see where the company is heading
and you know try to basically bring
these solutions
to solve those problems and this is how
you know basically from
the business perspective you try to be
you know ahead of
uh everyone and try to you know give the
customer what they need but from the
team perspective as a leader
right you have to actually know what
your team strengths are
know what you can do what you cannot do
and what is at hand
so uh with that you know you plan
for a particular feature or a particular
problem that you need to solve
and go with the team you know actually
it's not just you right
leader is just you know trying to guide
the team
in in the right direction that's all
it's the whole team that is behind you
that is making it happen
right and so when you know i i
understand that in terms of the strategy
and
it makes a lot of sense and now when it
gets translated to the day-to-day
so how do we how how does a
well-functioning team look like versus
perhaps one that is not going to be
sustainable in the long run
yeah i mean that's a good question
actually so many of the leaders they
struggle to you know when they move from
an engineering role into
uh i mean icy role we call it ic role
into a manager role uh struggle with you
know handling the teams
the reason is when they were uh ics they
actually were able to handle their own
problem they were not looking at
the whole system in a single chart in a
single frame
now when you become a manager what is
happening is you have multiple people
that you need to manage and still
deliver what is required for the product
now what does it entails to is on a
day-to-day basis if you look at it right
we
you know tactically the first thing you
need to do is of course you know
your emails are always there you know
you have to go through your emails and
figure out what the problems are and you
you have a dashboard that you create
you go through the dashboard oh what are
the problems today that we are seeing
are there any customers uh that are not
happy
when i say i'm not happy it doesn't mean
actually not happy
basically are they having any problems
do we need to solve the problems
then once you look at the dashboard and
figure out what
what you need to do you interact with
your team to figure out
okay what is our next few deliverables
that we are working on
what is that we need to do to make sure
this this particular release or this
particular feature or the product goes
out on time
right and then what you do is tactically
you actually plan that particular day
going through
the meetings see you you have meetings
every day right you know
especially with during this pandemic you
know a lot of people get zoom fatigued
but still you have to make sure the
business runs as usual
so what you do is you figure out okay
yes this particular release what are the
features that we are working on is all
working fine but how about what
you know what comes next so you have to
plan ahead and figure out oh what do i
need
so interact with your uh with your
architects interact with your
qe teams interact with your uh product
managers you know the whole day you're
mostly interacting with people
to get all the data you need and then
you use the data
basically mine the data and figure out
and plan
what you need to do next when i say next
it can be
a day or a week or a month you know it's
all about planning
now this this brings in uh problems uh
when you don't handle
you know this data appropriately and
actually when you have across your team
it's it's a little even more challenging
for the fact that
you need to be aware of the timeline i
mean the timings that they are working
on
working at as well as you know you need
to make sure
they're part of our team right you know
the basic problem with global teams is
the teams on the other side they always
think that oh
we are not we are not in the uh you know
um
world headquarters what does it mean
that means you know we are always on the
receiving end
so you need to break the chain you know
you need to break the
thinking saying that no it is not you
know you're the same team
here you go you work on this you have to
give them something independent so that
they can work on that
and plan for it and then talk to them on
a daily basis
so so these are some of the things that
i always you know have my dashboard
go through that and plan talk to people
and figure out what next
and how we do it right i i think that i
think that makes a lot of sense now
looking at your looking at your
experiences maybe you have a few
examples of of specific experiences
you've had where
where you know they gave you some
interesting insight into the world of
leadership
or you know entrepreneurship within an
organization
or or simply some things that i as young
entrepreneur can take with me as i go on
my journey and think
how can i make most of of my time and
the most impact
uh so uh when when i deal with uh uh
you know teams for example let's say uh
uh
when when you as a uh a new person
wants to actually create a team or
try to uh build a team or or even an
uh a company the first thing you need to
do is
hey do i have anyone that i can trust
can somebody trust me and
believe me in this idea that i'm trying
to do or believe me in this project or
a feature that i'm trying to do so you
need to have that personal relationship
with you know your people who are you're
trying to you know
uh talk to or where you're trying to uh
team up with
and then use them actually to act
the uh brainstorm the ideas that
brainstorm the features all that stuff
and then slowly you know once you have
confidence in what you're doing right
you should have your own confidence
and and uh the same way you you
actually trust your team and then use
that
whatever you have come up with right and
see how you can take it to the next
level
the next level can be basically you know
building a poc it can be
proving uh that this is what it is see
for example i'll give you an example
in in my current role right so we have
lot of innovation going on in this you
know public cloud private cloud
multi-cloud you know we talked about
multi-cloud you know multi-cloud is
nothing but a public cloud and a private
cloud
as well you know multiple public clouds
or multiple private loads it can be
anything
now we have lot of innovation going on
uh uh in that area
especially uh uh with vmware sitting at
you know the helm of all these things
now uh we came up with you know uh
some xyz uh product now i can't
quote the product but you know came up
with the product but the thing is it's
it's
entirely new so what do we do so i have
trust in my
uh uh engineer meaning in my architect
so we
tagged together we came up with you know
we did some brainstorming and of course
you know
uh he was the one who ran with all the
technicals
and i was the one who was i was the one
who set up everything
you know uh from the management
perspective what to do
you know how to do so then what we did
was
uh once we had everything ready then we
went to our management saying that this
makes sense here we go this is where the
uh
problem is this is how we will solve
this right in a multi-cloud environment
and and uh management was happy and they
said okay
we still have to see what you're trying
to do so we went back
and i i actually picked a few people you
know uh from the team who are interested
in this
and said you know what i'm gonna shield
you from the day-to-day
things of your current project and i'll
i'll try to manage that
but you need to work on this hundred
percent and i actually put them 100 on
this
within two weeks we did we did a poc
and my management is happy wow
and and we are actually converting that
into a product
wow that's very very yeah i mean it's
and so i
i guess it's mostly tactical on that
front yes sorry go ahead
well i think the one of the big
takeaways that i'm that i'm taking from
this you know
as a manager one of the the amazing
things that you ended up doing
uh was being able to understand that you
have a higher priority right now that
you have to prove something
that there's there's urgency there's
time sensitivity
there is a specific people that are
right for the task and being able to
delegate tasks and to shift shift
priorities around
being agile in a in a big corporate that
that's not an excellent feat to achieve
right
absolutely absolutely you know i meant
right and
i mean that's that's very good points
that bring up right you know
in a big company it is never easy to uh
you know bring something new
um as fast as you can uh in a startup
right because uh startups move very fast
they are very agile and you know
uh what we are trying to do here in
vmware is actually foster that culture
of
you know a startup and even though it is
big
of course you know we have all the
processes all that stuff still the
management is so
savvy you know tech savvy that
we always support our engineers and
believe me when i say this
vmware always cares about people
especially engineers and they give value
to the
uh the value to the uh all the
individual contributors all the
engineers
and whatever they bring to the table
takes high priority than anything else
so that's that's the whole and i would
say
magic that happens inside vmware you
know giving that freedom giving that
opportunity giving that you know
basically having that trust
in your engineers thinking that okay
they are going to do
it is where we are today
right as the empire and of course as i
mentioned right you know as a global
leader you know you should be aware of
all this stuff and you should
make sure such opportunities are
available not only to your team
locally in your headquarters but also to
your team you know elsewhere wherever it
is
that's where they will they'll feel that
they're included into everything you
know
right especially when we're looking at a
a post-covert world where there's
obviously hybrid
situations and teams are naturally
globally not just because of the
pandemic but because this is where we
are
heading as a society and so i think
that's something that's definitely uh
to take into account in in just a few
words when you're talking about
multi-cloud environments
what do you mean by that okay so that's
a good question so
multi-cloud environment is if you look
at uh
you know few years back all these
corporates all the big companies they
had their own data centers
still they have the data centers but
what they want is they want something
called as drs the rss disaster require
as well as they want migrations all that
stuff to happen
so what they're doing now is they are
saying okay we have our own presence
in my you know you know private cloud we
call that private cloud
now we need something in the public
cloud tomorrow if something happens
uh you know god forbid you know dearest
happens they do have a drs
site all that stuff but still they want
to have
an extra support or extra
backup for all that you know
workloads that you're that they are
working i mean that they are
running so what's going to happen is
they have
uh bought some you know uh probably
uh space you know as well as memory
you know network uh uh all that stuff
some bandwidth all that stuff
from the public clouds like azure like
aws like gcp
right and what they're doing is they're
trying to connect their private clouds
with the public cloud so this is the
multi-cloud environment and you have
your private clouds you have all these
public clouds now you want to have
presence in all of them
so how do i how do you do it that's
where you know our
vmware comes in you know vmware what it
does is basically it's it
it has a very big presence in private
cloud and what it is doing
is it's saying okay you know what you
want to get into public cloud
sure you know use our product you know
we have a product called vmc
on aws so use that product right
and we'll connect you to wherever you uh
you want so this is how
uh you know uh this just stuff you know
what we do of course
but this is multi-cloud environment
where we do all the connectivity where
we do all the orchestration where we do
everything else that the customers can
be happy to just you know
use it sounds amazing sure ramen and i
really want to thank you for for coming
here and sharing with me both your
your personal journey and your insights
into leadership especially in
in the big corporate but also the work
that you're doing sounds fascinating and
i want to take you back into your
childhood and
and ask you what really fascinated you
as a kid maybe a specific subject in
school or a passion hobby
okay so this is this is very uh thanks
for asking this is this is very funny
but you know believe me when you say
this
my background is is i'm a mechanical
engineer
i ended up in you know
i t you know basically high tech you
know how it happened
so when i was uh uh in my fifth grade
so computers were just coming you know
ms-dos right that's the first operating
system that i saw
and ms-dos came into you know one of the
colleges near my
uh school and luckily one of uh
my relative was the uh dean
for that particular department and
that's how i got introduced to computers
and you know how you know why
uh i like like the computers i used to
play prince of persia if you remember
that
uh i don't know but you know prince of
persia used to be my favorite game
and that's how i got introduced you know
what what happened you know once i
played the game it picked my brain
saying that
yeah i mean there's this something
called as floppy so
of course they were big at the time uh
but how can this particular thing
you know run on that that picked my
brain
and you know i i actually was pursuing
my
uh you know um computers you know
all the stuff that i uh wanted to learn
about computers
on the side from you know my relative
at the end of the day when i went into
my college you know engineering college
i took mechanical engineering for the
fact that you know
i i wanted to marry right this
mechanical stuff
into uh you know with artificial brain
you know the
a that we talk about today you know it's
called as robotics at the time
so that was my passion i wanted to do
that and
of course you know i did it my undergrad
but you know at the end of the day
uh even at home right now i think
and you know i i do lot of this uh uh
robotic stuff
programming all that so that's that's
something funny you know where i was
attracted to this
very very cool and and what inspires you
today where do you find inspiration so
uh my inspiration comes from my uh
teacher
who actually imported this knowledge
when i was really young you know when
when i was in my 10th grade and you know
there was no google at the time and
actually yahoo was just setting it up so
the only thing that i could get
in from information from were from the
library or from
you know my teacher my teacher is a math
teacher and
you know he uh actually learned about
computers all that stuff
like the way i did but you know he he
went to a premier institution
in india called indian staff science and
which is like a research institute you
can talk about stanford here it's
similar to that
back in india so i learned everything
from him
and today what i'm what i'm today is
just because of him so
that is my inspiration and he he was
remember he was
about to retire five years away from
retirement but he did not
he did not stop learning
that's that's amazing
wow very very cool and what are three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
well i mean people call me a little bit
uh
you know adventurous because
i always want people to take those risks
and
really leave the uh you know whatever
comes out of it leave it leave it aside
and you know work towards that yeah
remember
when you are adventurous then you try to
basically invent something
that's that's what i believe in and i do
that and of course i'm ambitious
uh again you know that's the same
example i i
always want to achieve something more
than
what is right in front of my eyes
right and and the finally you know uh
what i heard from my people
is basically i'm i'm uh very balanced
and honest
so it's not that you know i always push
my team to
you know deliver something i always uh
you know be very cognizant to the fact
that you know i
i have some empathy of course right and
i have to show my empathy all that stuff
and i empathize with you know people
during these court times how they work
all that stuff
so i keep myself balanced you know
in fact you know if we have a long
weekend i always encourage my team not
to work
and whenever it is required i always ask
them hey we need to deliver this
so i'm basically balanced so these are
the three words i can
put together i love it
thank you so much for everything this
was fantastic thank you for the
inspiration and stay safe and stay
healthy
thanks michael for the opportunity and
stay safe and
healthy too